hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in section 8 of his inquiry concerning
human understanding david hume has some
rather
interesting to say the least reflections
on the nature of crime
justice human actions punishment
what laws are supposed to be about and
he begins this section
by telling us that the basic
assumption of laws they're all
founded on rewards and punishment and
you know this is the way that laws work
they tell us do this
and if you don't do this then you will
be punished and
uh do this and you'll be rewarded but
you know that's kind of a stretch to say
that that's that's the real
foundation of laws there's also like the
moral norm involved and all that
but it tells us that it's being supposed
as a fundamental principle that
these motives have a regular and uniform
influence on the mind and both produce
the good
and prevent the bad
actions and he says we can give to this
influence what name we please
but it's usually conjoined with the
action so what he means here
are what we typically call motives
motivations
intentions now there's a lot of
looseness in
moral psychology and in ethics in
picking out exactly what you know a
motive is as opposed to an intention if
you read somebody
coming a little bit later than hume like
jeremy bentham
for example you you notice that he has a
quite rigid distinction between the two
of them
but we can sort of lump them all in
together here
and say that hume is is interested in
the fact that the law
looks to the motive of the person or
assumes the motive of the person
in its administration of rewards and
punishments so let's look at these two
assumptions built into this a little bit
more closely
hume has been arguing in section 8 that
motives do have a uniform
influence on the human mind so if we do
understand the motive that a person has
that is
the way in which their thinking works
or their what we call motivational
structure which is how they want to get
the goods and avoid evils
right if we understand all of those
sorts of things
we should be able to predict the way a
person
will behave or to explain why they did
the action that they did and so this is
very important for
legal matters and punitive or reward
matters isn't it
we want to say okay this person
here is incorrigible they're always
going to behave this way
incorrigible means unable to be
corrected right and you would be
correcting somebody with reward and
punishment
this person here is
screwed up but they are corrigible we
can
modify the way in which their motives
work
and then produce the actions if we
tinker around with their motivational
structure
so if we notice that you know people who
let's take a great example people who
commit
revenge killings right are motivated by
this entire dynamic over here and we see
that somebody
is you know for whatever reason we think
that
that's going on in their head we can
assume that they're going to engage in a
revenge killing
or if we know that people steal when
they
are at a last resort and hungry and we
see that people over here are at a last
resort in hungary we can say well
they're gonna steal right so motives
have a uniform
influence motives produce the good
or bad actions or also some you know to
prevent
uh evil he says as well so
you know this is i think pretty
uncontroversial
as well so hume thinks that he says
laws are basically about this
we can give to this influence what name
we please but as it is usually conjoined
with the action he says it must be
esteemed a
cause and looked upon as an instance of
that necessity
that we would hear establish and we can
understand this necessity just to remind
ourselves
in two connected ways you know we have
this
uh sort of habit or custom
built up on the basis of observing
things out there in the world and when
it comes to human motivations we can
also look at ourselves
and say well i behave this way i bet
other people will behave this way as
well
and so there's the things that happen
that there's some sort of constant
conjunction
presumably this motive is constantly
conjoined with
this action over here hume thinks we can
actually like look back into history
or across cultures and see constants of
this sort
and then there is the sort of inferences
going on in our own minds
both of which he says are instances of
necessity we're grasping
what we at least understand of causality
so
this is a very important why
hume says the only proper object of
hatred or
vengeance is a person or creature
endowed with thought and consciousness
when any criminal or injurious actions
excite
that passion hatred or vengeance
it is only by their relation to the
person or connection
with him so you know when we ask
ourselves okay what is it that we
actually do feel
hatred or vengeance towards huma is
going to say it's not
actually the action per se
it's the action as indicative of
something
else now he goes on and he tells us that
actions by their own nature are
temporary and
perishing so if i uh
talk to you in a mean way today you'd be
like ah dr sadler that guy's a jerk
you know maybe i'm not a jerk though
maybe i'm just a jerk
today in this instance with you but i'm
you know
talking uh nicely with somebody an hour
later right
actions can can change very much from
situation to situation
and they're perishing they they
disappear once you're done with the
action there
there are effects of the action but the
action is gone
right the action can be as he says
against you know morality or religion or
pick whatever you want and therefore it
can be blameable so you can say don't do
that kind of action
you know when we're talking to little
kids or like hey quit hitting your
brother
right don't push uh that person down the
stairs
quit pulling the dog's tail right we say
don't do that action
because it's against some sort of rule
or some sort of
standard right but the actions by
themselves
aren't really what we we want to punish
now that's kind of interesting because
if you think about the way laws are
typically framed
quite often laws or rules or procedures
whatever we want to say
look at the action they say you do this
i don't care why you did it
you're getting the stick you're getting
punished right you're getting a fine
now when we administer laws as rational
agents we often start to think okay well
why did this person do this maybe
maybe we don't come down hard on them
about that maybe we come up with some
alternative punishment
that will be rehabilitative rather than
merely
retributive or punitive right so he says
that
actions where they don't proceed from
some cause and the character and
disposition of the person who performed
them
they can neither redown to his honor if
good nor infamy if
evil the actions may be blamable but the
person
is not answerable for them if they're
just sort of temporary
and as they proceed from nothing in him
that's durable and constant leave
nothing of that nature behind him
it is impossible he can upon their
account become the object of punishment
or vengeance now it's interesting hume
doesn't really talk about this here
but it's interesting to think that well
if that's true if it's really just
persons
endowed with thought and consciousness
who we feel hatred or vengeance towards
and we do so because actions are
indications of what he will a little bit
later say
our internal character passions
or affections what's actually going on
when we want to punish somebody when we
feel anger
resentment hatred vengeance towards them
well we must be assuming that the
actions that we're observing
are indeed indices of
a stable settled character so when we
see somebody
shoplifting we're like that's a
shoplifter instead of just saying
oh that person is shoplifting right now
we say that person does that sort of
thing now if it
another thing that hume doesn't talk
about if this ties in with
mindsets or prejudices that we have
already it becomes much easier to
impose those sorts of interpretations on
people and then therefore want to
punish but he says that in a lot of
cases
um a person isn't actually
uh that bad because it's it's not part
of
their their character it's not part of
who they
are right um
he tells us if we want to jump ahead a
little bit and i think it's worth
pausing on here
it tells us that the mind of a human
being is so formed by nature that on the
appearance of certain characters
dispositions and actions
it immediately feels the sentiment of
approbation or blame
nor are there any emotions more
essential to its frame and constitution
so this is part of our nature to make
these snap judgments about people
and then he tells us the characters
which engage our approbation the things
that we are
positively uh oriented towards you could
say that we praise
are those chiefly such as contribute to
the peace and security of human society
the characters which excite blame are
chiefly those that tend to public
detriment
and disturbance and so you know
kind of a utilitarian way of looking at
things and you can you can look at other
parts of human's moral theory to get a
bigger
uh picture of that now
one thing that he says here that's
really quite striking
why is hume talking about all this it's
part of a larger argument saying that we
we are all subject to necessity so
if indeed we were all subject to
necessity you would say well why do we
punish anybody
you know uh that's that's a question
that hume just sort of leaves out
you can say well we're necessitated to
punish in that case right
but he's interested in in saying well
what would happen if we deny
this doctrine of necessity if we say
that human beings have motivations
and they may steer a person towards
something but it's ultimately within
that person's power
to go against their motivational
structure and to kind of choose
between them he actually tells us that
if we deny the doctrine of necessity
we wind up with an absurd result which
is that
nobody is criminal he says
according to the principle which denies
necessity and consequently
causes a man is as pure and untainted
after committing the most horrid crime
as at the first moment of his birth nor
is his character any wise concerned in
his actions
since they are not derived from it and
the wickedness of the one can never be
used as a proof of the depravity
of the other he's saying that if you let
in
you know free will in the libertarian
sense as we say in philosophy
where we can actually decide between
things where we can have motives and
then decide to resist them
if that's the case then we can't really
punish anybody because nobody's a
criminal ever
now that is a really weird argument to
make isn't it
you would think that i mean and hume
knows this from other people in his own
time
that if you think that people have free
will
they're actually more responsible at
least in most people's eyes
for the good or bad use that they make
of their free will
and so you know i think most people
would say well you can reward or punish
them
on the basis of whether they they
you know followed this motive in the
right way
by their own choice or whether they
followed this one
and i think a lot of people would
probably say
that if you did have motives that
absolutely compel you to choose the way
that you do maybe you're actually less
responsible but hume
wants to say no no it's the other way
around
the reason why we're able to punish is
because deep down inside we really think
that people
who have characters it's it's absolutely
determining
what they do he does however bring up
mitigating circumstances as we call them
today
and his discussion of these is quite
interesting he says
men are not blamed for such actions as
they perform ignorantly
and causely whatever may be the
consequences why
because it's not part of their character
he says the principles of those actions
are only momentary and terminating them
alone
and the principles of those actions in
that case is the mistaken
understanding of the situation that
they're in
right so we exculpate
people for acting
out of ignorance this goes all the way
back to
you know aristotle when we're talking
about legal and
moral theory right he also talks about
actions performed hastily that is
quickly
and unpremeditatedly
he says that we are less blamed and now
notice he doesn't say
we're not blamed at all he says we're
less blamed for such actions
as performed hastily and
unpremeditatedly
than for such as proceed from
deliberation the thing about
you know the way the distinctions that
we make in terms of murder right
we have murder in the first degree where
you're like i want to get that bastard
i'm gonna like figure out a plan and
then i'll wait for him and maybe poison
him or stab him with a sword or
something like that
we say that's premeditated or deliberate
what if i am in a bar and
something gets out of hand and i get
really angry with somebody and i
break a bottle and i slash his throat uh
we'll probably call that murder in the
second degree
we say that i was motivated by my as
humans going to call it here
hasty temper right and he says a hasty
temper
though a constant cause or principle in
the mind
operates only by intervals and effects
not the
whole character we might say well how
how much
of that hasty temper do we have to have
how
constant does it have to be before we're
like lock that that
that person up punish them right so
you know he doesn't go into detail there
that's where we might want to make a
judgment call
he also has a very interesting short
discussion of repentance and he tells us
repentance wipes off every crime
there's a big if if attended
with a reformation of life and manners
why because it shows us that the person
is not entirely motivated by
the motives or motive that causally
made them engage in those criminal
actions so let's take the shoplifter
right the shoplifter
is hungry one day and they're like i'm
gonna stick a loaf of bread underneath
my
my coat at the convenience store and run
out of here
and you know then they eat the bread and
they're filled up and they're like oh
that was a bad thing for me to do
somebody catches them on the camera
bring them in
and the judge is like you're a horrid
person shoplifting from
wherever and they're like oh yeah i feel
really bad about it and then the judge
is like
um well okay maybe uh you're not quite
as bad as i thought
and then it turns out that they like
went in later on and you know like
slipped two dollars to the cashier
when the cashier wasn't looking there's
there's like a an example of making good
right
so why does this matter to him all three
of these things
show us that the person's character is
not totally bad
and therefore they they shouldn't be
punished to the same degree
or maybe not punished at all as somebody
who is indeed criminal and and so this
is you know
hume's uh treatment of this here you
could say that
in general hume is is looking at things
you know when we talk about theories of
punishment in a rather
utilitarian manner where he's not
interested in people
punishing just for the sake of punishing
he thinks that there's some sort of
social function involved here
he does as i pointed out a little bit
earlier realize that there is an almost
automatic process by which
if we see actions that we associate
with bad motives we do tend to
impose those those motives uh on on the
action as the interpretation for why the
person behaved that way
but if we get more information later on
maybe
we uh don't punish them and we don't
punish them
or we lessen the punishment precisely
because
we think that their motives are not as
bad
you